let's move on to this question from Gino
how can I be a minimalist with a
roommate how do I make my roommate a
minimalist now that's how much she knows
asking well I you know what but
sometimes that question can be can be
translated that way and sometimes that's
actually what they mean right right
yeah and you know what that it's it's an
aspiration like I want everyone else to
be just like me no actually we don't
want everyone else to be just like us
because that'd be a relatively boring
life right so I think the first thing to
think about here
I object slightly to the question
because it presupposes that you can't
have a roommate if you're a minimalist
right yeah well yeah and so think about
I mean I think about yours and Mariah's
situation or vexes in my situation with
Ella and and I think it has to do first
off with with coexisting with other
people and appreciating them for who
they are yeah so let's talk about
minimalism or no minimalism yes how do
you be a good roommate ah how do you
have a good roommate yeah so you go out
of your way to add as much value as you
can you go out of your way to support
your roommate to respect your roommate
to appreciate the differences and if you
act like that I mean that's the Golden
Rule man you treat someone how you want
to be treated so if you go out of your
way to do these things for a roommate
the hope is is that the roommate is
going to reciprocate all of these
amazing things that you've done for them
and the same thing goes with minimalism
it's it is something where if you have a
roommate and you go to them and you say
hey there are a few expectations I would
like to you know to ask if you would be
willing to do right um you know the
common areas let's keep them clean with
the kitchen you know let's let's keep
that stuff clean and if you have done
all that upfront work of being
supportive with your roommate and
showing them that you respect them you
respect the differences even at that
point where you appreciate the
differences well your roommate is
probably going to be probably going to
be okay with with making these anyone
comp compromises but agreeing with these
community rules essentially yeah I mean
there's no way that you can go to a
roommate and say hey look I'm a
minimalist that means you should be a
minimalist ooh we've got we've got too
many couches in here we got too many
chair we got too many silverware I mean
that is that's the wrong way to approach
a roommate the best way again is to it's
to show support and then ask for ask for
support back now sometimes like I had a
roommate that they don't give you the
support back sure no matter how much you
support them and in that case well I had
to go find a new roommate yeah I think
that that's the keys we're also not
stuck realizing that like this might be
the ideal roommate situation for the
next month the next six months the next
year yeah but in it doesn't mean you're
gonna be roommates in perpetuity very
rarely are two people roommates for the
rest of their lives right if you're
feeling overwhelmed you feel a bit of
despair despair says something about
your future realize that the future can
change and so maybe this this roommate
situation is necessary right now but you
can change it as well and so you don't
need to be with that roommate forever
and maybe it just means finding another
place where you can be by yourself or
finding another roommate who's going to
share your similar values but with that
said you're gonna you're never gonna
find the perfect roommate who looks
exactly like you who shares the same
exact identical preferences as you yeah
mariah is by far the best roommate best
romantic part I mean this is like the
one of the best relationships I have
ever had in my life and there are still
nuances that I that it's my problem not
hers where there are preferences that I
have that I have to I have to look at
and say hey Ryan this is your preference
that's okay that this is your preference
but do not force your preference on
Mariah if anything if it's really
bothering me that much
I will go to Ryan I will say hey I've
got this one particular preference that
I really would love to have your help on
and she's so awesome that she is usually
willing to to help me out but you know
even if there is something where it's
totally ridiculous if it's totally
absurd that I'm that I'm asking and and
she points that out no Ryan that's
ridiculous well that's where that's
where it's my turn to to give it makes
me think about the us box yes
so another you know so the us box we
talk about this a lot where with every
relationship there is an S box and
you've got to look at how often am I
giving too
at us box if you're just taking from
that us box well then guess what you are
a your succubus no one wants to be a
succubus yeah but if you're giving to
that us box and the other person is
giving to that us box
well usually that makes for a really
really good relationship and sometimes
giving to that us box it means not
putting my preference first and and I
mean obviously Mariah and I put each
other's preferences first as much as we
can but there's some times where it just
doesn't work I'm trying to think of an
example right now I can't think of
anything because we get along so
freaking well but but I've got some
because I'm so neurotic yeah go for it
with me and back so so yeah what's a
preference you have that actually I know
a huge one dude you've got a kid yeah
that is the biggest dude out of all of
so was me Josh his brother Jerome we had
another friend it was the four of us who
always hung out in high school and I am
the last of the four to have a kid and I
really really thought it was gonna be
Josh because his preference was so stuck
on
I don't want children dude this yeah
this was um this is something that up
until you met Beck's
right it was a deal-breaker yeah and
even when I met backs it was like oh
this is totally reframing the way that I
think about the world because I mean you
have some options here right it's in
order to be a good roommate or a good
partner or yeah when I think of a
roommate really just talked about living
partners cuz you are a partner in living
and I would get Mariah's my roommate
yeah and she's also my romantic partner
she's my like a spouse equivalent yeah
yeah that's the the the the Jonathan
Jonathan friends in term and and so you
know when I think about when I think
about roommates or partners or anyone in
which we are in a relationship with
where we go wrong is when we think about
me and we're not thinking about we amen
dude I am so bad at that man and and so
one thing that catch myself all the time
Oh like we're moving I'm moving and I'm
like no no we are moving right it wasn't
it like we were talking about moving to
LA the way I phrased it on the show
sounds like Mariah wasn't coming
that's la we were tweeting you I are
your partner coming with you or that
yeah and so for me is so important one
of the things that that we do is we
should have to have shared preferences
and in the sense that like if I want to
bring something new into the house and
we both need to agree on that thing
otherwise it doesn't come into the house
at all now that is an ideal relationship
but also means I have to sacrifice
something I would really like to have
this widget or this thing that I would
get value from but if we aren't gonna
get value from it's gonna get in the way
of someone else's preferences then we
agree to not bring in a house and the
opposite is also true if Beck's wants to
bring in you know some painting that I
don't like or something we both need to
agree on it but here's the nice thing
about that it keeps the house
aggressively simple there's far fewer
things to clean but the things we do
have in there we both really enjoy so
we're not having these unnecessary
disagreements or arguments about those
things there's also some words that we
won't use like I won't use the word hate
I hate that idea I also won't attack the
other person yeah and I think that's
that's really important never attack the
the person or even their actions instead
I will share my preferences Amen dude
you know earlier I with this question I
said something about setting some
expectations that I mean that is in an
ideal world that sounds great just go
with your roommate and set expectations
but you don't literally want to go to
your roommate and say hi I have
expectations I'd like to set with you
right like that is gonna put it off on
on that's gonna start off on the wrong
foot with that conversation so when
having that conversation to your point
when you're talking to someone it is it
is I always talk about the I versus you
so if I'm saying something negative or
not negative but if I'm asking someone
else to correct something they're doing
I will try to put it on myself as much
as possible so for example hey Josh I
really appreciate our relationship you
have been my best friend you know since
the fifth grade and for that I am so
grateful for I've got this problem
though man where I need to have 10
glasses of water on this table and I
know that that's a lot of glasses
for you and I really want to respect
your preferences but I really really
need those 10 glasses of water on this
table while we record a podcast would
you be willing to help me out with my
problem is there anything that we can do
and maybe it's not ten glasses maybe
it's five glasses I'm obviously using
something really arbitrary and
non-existent right now right but but the
whole point is is that having a
conversation with someone especially
when you're trying to get them to change
their actions or to change their
behavior you have to a make it their
decision and you have to put all of the
all of the the guilt or the negativity
whatever it is that you're projecting
you've got to put that on yourself
because if it is indeed a projection
then you want to avoid projecting anyway
because really what you're doing is
escalating in that situation the
opposite is also true when I think about
quite often in past relationships I've
been in or even in my current
relationship to a much lesser extent is
yeah is everything okay is everything
okay
because we hide sometimes when we have
some sort of problem you can see us
someone's features quite often not me
because I don't wear my heart on my
sleeve as much as most people but but we
go to people is everything okay you sure
everything's okay
well there's a book by a friend Colin
right it's called some thoughts about
relationships right and one of the it's
it's a bunch of policies about
relationships it could be intimate
relationships friendships roommates
whomever and one of the the policies he
has it's called the aisle telling you
policy mm-hmm if something is wrong it
is my duty to tell you about that and
that way I'm never going around
questioning backs where are you sure
everything's okay yeah you're you
worried about something not telling me
is there something that you're not
telling no because we have this policy
and it would be actually I would be
disingenuous of me and it would be a lie
of omission if I didn't tell her that
something was wrong I would be lying if
I didn't tell her something's wrong
because we have this policy between each
other
the I will tell you policy has made me
be more upfront about my feelings and
also the issues I have one last thing
that has helped me is sitting down and
and this is the last thing I will
recommend here for Gino is have a
conversation with your roommate and
don't say here are the expectations I
have to just say hey what are 10 things
you would like to see me improve yeah if
you sit down and say what are 10 things
that I can improve mmm do you think the
person is not going to turn around and
say hey one of 10 things I can do to be
more supportive because Ryan when you
and I were we were roommates for 13
months we first moved out to Montana we
moved to that cabin a little nowhere for
months then me you and Colin right we
all lived in the the same asymmetrical
house when we started our publishing
company together we lived there for
seven months and you two were the two
best roommates I'd ever had mainly cuz
you're the only roommates ever had and I
I know it's hard I'm really difficult to
live with that's an expectation I set
with anyone but oh you're not bad but I
it's an expectation I set yeah here's
why I'm really difficult to to live with
I have I have OCD I have certain
preferences and both of you even though
you had different preferences you are
really respectful of my preferences
absolutely well because dude if I want
you and Colin to be respectful of my
preferences I have to respect your
preferences
you